How does that make you feel? I'm
not sure. It's hard to say. Yeah.
Well there's an episode of
Syrah geology coming in.
I just don't have time for this right now.
So
hello world.
It's Saroj.
Have you ever had a hard time trying to
understand what someone is trying to say
to you?
People aren't confusing.
I don't even understand my
own emotions half the time,
much less what someone else
is feeling or thinking.
When we read a piece of text
or listen to someone speak.
Our brains are performing tone analysis.
We're trying to understand
the meaning behind the words.
That is the sentiment and
the emotions and the style.
It's not an easy task at all, but this
is something machines can do pretty well.
Now it's all a part of a subfield of
machine learning called natural language
processing.
Standard approaches to NLP a couple of
years ago in both extracting a set of
features from some labeled
piece of text that feature,
and we're usually end grams and grams
have nothing to do with Graham crackers
even though they are extremely delicious
and grams are just sequences of words.
So a Unigram is one word by
grandma's to and Trigram is three.
Once the end grims were extracted,
the next step was to train a linear model
on some pre labeled data so they could
classify similar texts.
The process of feature extraction saw a
hugely forward when Google open source,
something called word to Vec,
word to Vec is a toolkit that
helps encode words into vectors.
These vectors are representations of
words called word embeddings that are
learned by training on a given corpus.
The tool kit consists
of two distinct models,
skip gram and continuous bag of words.
The skip grant model predicts
the neighboring words given
the current word and a
given window.
In contrast,
the bag of words model
predicts the current word
given the neighboring words and
given window. These models both
help predict and code words.
Once we had these vectors,
we can use them to do all sorts of text
classification, including tone analysis,
deep learning.
One of the first papers to show that deep
learning could improve text analysis,
who's called convolutional neural
networks for sentence classification.
Although CNNS were intended for computer
vision. These guys applied it to NLP.
They first train the CNN on a set of word
vectors that Google extracted from 100
billion word corpus using their own
word to Vec toolkit. After training,
the CNN had built representations
of all sorts of word categories.
Since the vectors weren't
labeled in any way,
the training was considered unsupervised.
After they had a train on
a set of Google vectors,
they then train it using labeled data
so that he could perform sentiment
analysis.
A later paper called Tex categorization
using LSTM for region embeddings
improved on it.
They did the same basic experiment,
but the key difference is that they didn't
just use a CNN to create embeddings.
They also use a long
short term memory network.
On LSTM is a type of recurrent neural
network that can remember dependencies
from way back in the sequence of data
and they found that they had the best
classification result.
When they combine the embeddings
from both the LSTM and the CNN,
just like two peas in a algorithm,
that was terrible.
They also found that embedding
regions that sets of words.
What's more effective than
embedding single words.
This idea of abstractions of a hierarchy
of knowledge in a given document helped
inspire a fresh paper released just two
months ago called hierarchical attention
networks for document classification.
These guys said,
let's create a new neural
architecture to model a document.
It starts by encoding words and applying
an attention mechanism to extract the
most important words. Then it encodes
a sentences using the weights.
It learned applies an attention
mechanisms to that to,
to extract the most important sentences.
It uses those weights to
build document level vectors.
So it's creating vectors for each layer
of attraction within a document and
building them off of each other.
The encoder for each of these
levels is called a gru neural net.
So after they initialize
the model using vectors,
they got using word to beck a trended on
labeled data and doing this with their
novel neural architecture pretty much
outperformed all previous attempts.
So how do we implement this
stuff ourselves? Well as
professor [inaudible] says,
deep learning requires a rocket,
the model and rocket fuel that data,
but sometimes you just want to get shit
done and training is to time expensive.
That's why we're going to use IBM's
Watson Api to perform tone analysis on an
example set. First we'll need to sign up
for their cloud service called blue mix.
Once we registered,
we'll click on Watson,
then tone analyzer or create a new service
using the standard plan which lets us
try it out for free so no
need to enter a credit card,
which is perfect because I'm poor.
Then we'll click on service credentials
and record our username and password
since we'll need them to
authenticate from our web APP.
Then we can generate a new note express
web app using NPM and the express
generator module in our APP will import
our Watson developer cloud npm module,
which acts as a thin javascript
wrapper around their API.
We have two routes here,
both of our index page.
We'll start with the get route and we
make a get request to the index page.
We want to display some html that
we can send programmatically. Here.
We'll send an input form that
asks for some corporates.
Then in our post trout will retrieve
the input that the user submits via the
post request. Then initialize
the tone analyzer variable,
filling our credentials and call the tone
function using the user input variable
as the parameter. This will return
to the analysis of the text as Jason,
which we can view in terminal.
Let's try it out.
As you can see it race the Corbett's on
three levels, emotions, language, style,
and social tendencies.
You'll get back a percentage for each
of three language styles and five social
tendencies. It does this at both the
document level and sentence level.
Tone analysis is a tool you can use to
better your writing and be more clear
about the message you're trying to convey.
Dope links for you down below.
Please subscribe for more ml videos.
I've got to go fix an indentation error,
so thanks for watching.